i think that there were at least two
meetings with the queen
one in the gardens of windsor just
before the funeral
and a further private one-to-one meeting
between harry and the queen so this has
been an opportunity for something
of a family reconciliation harry's
incredibly fond
of his grandmother they share a very
close relationship it would have been
very important to him
that he got to have some time with his
grandmother before he went back to la
you know this was of course a private
meeting and i think there's a great
sensitivity over any conversations that
are happening between harry
and his family members because
everything blew up when details of his
peace talks with william was suddenly
broadcast on the american airwaves so
as you might expect it's being kept very
tight
being kept very close no details of
these conversations are being
leaked but it is safe to say that there
were meetings with family members well
it was prince charles's idea to get
the boys together after the wake there
really wasn't any time given that
prince harry was in self-isolation for
those days leading up to the funeral
for them to get together but after the
funeral there was an opportunity and it
was charles's idea for them to take a
walk around
the grounds of windsor castle where they
were outside so obviously adhering to
covid regulations
where they couldn't be eavesdropped upon
and where it was just
the three of them so i think it was
quite an important meeting
as i say it was charles's suggestion
william was also there
and harry was very happy to go along
with that and that really was the first
time
that the three of them father and son
were able to come together
and have a private informal meeting
well i think the hope is that these
conversations will continue i mean this
was just an icebreaker anyone thinking
that everything has been resolved
awake i think is sadly you know
misguided it's going to take more than
one or two conversations but i think
this is a significant start let's not
forget
that before harry arrived in the uk all
conversations had basically ceased
so this was the ice breaker this was the
baby step
and yes it is everyone's hope not least
the queen that these conversations will
continue
continue productively and crucially
not be leaked to the media things were
not going to be resolved
in one or two family meetings so while
this has been
an important step i think there's still
quite a way to go
the idea that harry's suddenly going to
come around to william's way of thinking
and vice versa
i think is is a way off i think there do
need to be
more conversations there's clearly still
a lot of hurt
a lot of resentment and a degree of
mistrust
i think on both parts so it's early days
but i think the hope is that
come july when we are hoping to see the
brothers stand
once again shoulder by shoulder to
unveil the statue in memory of their
mother
that the relationship will be stronger
and in a better place
the unveiling of the diamond statue is
going to be an
important date it's firmly cemented in
both of the brothers calendars
well we don't know if megan will be
coming over for the unveiling of the
statue we do know that this baby is due
in the summer we think it's june but of
course she was late
with her first pregnancy archery was a
week overdue so she's late this time
around i think it really rules out
any long-haul travel um to the uk
but it it's very much the hope that
harry will be here
and i think everyone is hoping that we
will see the brothers
shoulder by shoulder to unveil that
statue in memory of their mother diana
always said to them
always stay close don't ever fall out
she would be devastated that that is
what happened
and she would be wanting them to feed
her together for that unveiling of the
statue in her honor
well i think kate played a big part in
getting william and harry talking and
you could see when she went to speak to
harry after the funeral
he visibly relaxed his shoulders dropped
he just looked relieved to be included
because i think up until that point
he felt very much like he was getting
the cold shoulder from most of his royal
relatives
um kate's really gone out of her way to
be a peacemaker and to help the brothers
get
back on track i think the idea of seeing
this reprisal of the fab four
harry and megan william and kate is
really so
far down the future it's almost quite
hard to even
envisage it at the moment so much has
happened there is so much hurt
on either side i think the first step is
william and harry
getting the relationship back on track i
know it was always harry's intention
that his children would be close to
william and kate's children he wanted
them to grow up close
as families there is now an ocean
between them
i think there will be a reconciliation
and i think we will see the four of them
together
on occasions in the future
you